[Applause]
le pen is a leading candidate in the
french presidential race
the first round of voting is on april
23rd which will narrow the field to two
for a runoff election on may 7th
marquinda penn is a far-right candidate
and
represents the front national the
national front which is the far-right
party
the national front has existed for a
little over 40 years
and marlene le pen has been running the
party since january two thousand eleven
marching pen is the daughter of the
founder of the national front jamari le
pen
he founded it in the early 1970s and it
was considered a pretty racist
anti-semitic party
and always very marginalized
the party was seen as anti-semitic in
large part because her father
had often minimized the holocaust
exists
[Music]
has distanced herself from her father
since 2015.
in part that's because she has tried to
change the message of the party and
change
the branding of the party excluded
from the national front my very own
father
we could not tolerate words
unacceptable words that would lead to a
caricature of our movement
by removing her father le pen hoped to
move the party away from anti-semitism
but a recent comment has undercut those
efforts
speaking to the press marine le pen
denied that france was responsible for
the verdeev roundup which took place
when french authorities arrested jews
and brought them to the velazquez indoor
cycling track in paris for eventual
delivery to nazi concentration camps
she said this despite the fact that
french president jacques shirak formally
acknowledged guilt on behalf of the
french state
in 1995 by questioning french
culpability in the holocaust her
comments have reopened old wounds
but for the time being le pen remains a
leading contender as she has been
throughout the campaign
and that's largely due to her successful
efforts to rebrand the national front
instead of being seen as anti-semites le
pen has worked to portray the party as
protectors of french identity and french
values
originated
[Music]
her big thing is about you know france
for the french
which gets into some of her policies
which actually we would perceive
as racist or xenophobic but she sees
them as
returning to a sort of mythical france
in a way it reminds us a little bit of
trump
the forgotten men and women of our
country
will be forgotten no longer
[Applause]
i am very happy about the election of
donald trump
i think that the united states will once
again regain its former image in the
world
which had become very damaged to marine
le pen
there is a certain french culture that
should be upheld and that that's being
lost in the tide of globalization she's
particularly anti-globalization
she's against the european union and she
would like to
radically reduce the number of
immigrants we're not going to welcome
any more people
stop we're full up during the 2015
refugee crisis
asylum seekers fled to europe from north
africa and the middle east
eventually landing in places like calais
france home to a notorious refugee camp
called the jungle
many europeans felt overwhelmed by the
sudden influx
and marlene the pen sees the opportunity
to elevate her nationalist platform
france didn't absorb the same numbers of
people as germany did or parts of
northern europe but
at the same time there was a sense that
it was out of control that
europe did not know how to control its
borders
[Music]
[Applause]
even though it was not connected having
the attacks in paris in the fall of 2015
and then again
in the in the summer of 2016 in nice
exacerbated a sense
of a changing europe reports are coming
in of an attack
a shooting in central paris hearing at
least 20 shots
and seeing more than 15 dead two young
men
no older than 25 with kalashnikovs the
fear of attacks the actuality of attacks
tend to bolster support for closing
borders
closing down the immigration policies
and
and turning an eye on the community that
people feel is
at fault while many leaders carefully
avoided making any assumptions about the
perpetrators
i don't want to speculate at this point
uh in terms of who was responsible for
this
marine le pen was quick to point the
finger speaking on the floor of the
european parliament shortly after the
attacks
she forcefully blamed islamic
fundamentalism for the tragedy in paris
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2010 france was home to nearly 5
million muslims
over a million more than the united
states a country nearly five
times the size of france and many french
muslims
are perceived as far more religious than
they are french
in part that is due to the very visual
issue of the veil
in public space an issue that has been
under debate in france
for over 25 years right now as of 2004
it's not allowed in public schools but
they've stopped short of banning it in
the street because that's seen as a
personal liberty scenario right
marine le pen would like to ban it in
general
[Music]
liberty egalita fraternity
by setting classic liberal ideals
against islamic fundamentalism
marlene le pen promotes french
nationalism by claiming she is
protecting french
identity similarly she has framed
globalization
as a threat to french values
said she will hold a referendum to pull
france out of the eu
she would like to ask for a frexit as we
just had a brexit she'd like return to a
sovereign currency
and she she very much would like to
return to a france of a
very of a different era
[Music]
if france was to be able to be actually
removed it would be the end of the
european experiment as we know it
as the national front's poll numbers
have risen over the past decade the
rhetoric of other political candidates
has begun to shift to the right
the parties to the center right begin to
adopt a number of her ideas
even if she doesn't succeed there's a
conversation taking place
that is much much more skeptical of
immigration
now it's become racialized and tinged
with this
sort of anti-islam islamophobia space as
well
the real question is does do european
nations
are they nimble enough to move into a
space of multiculturalism and is that
what they want
and one of the things that you know
malignant pen will say is
this is not a battle for an election
this is a battle between
globalization and patriotism so she sets
it up as the idea that one
is not a patriot unless one buys into
the idea
of a very specific type of france which
a lot of people would see themselves
left out of
[Music]
you